like you want divor
me
yes a swellow was probably thinking dang
I should have done more at the strip
club last night just kidding in
actuality this man is hurt take your
time asell Kanani tells asell she wants
to get a divorce and he has a visceral
reaction plus I will punch you in the
face you bring
my JY almost gives biged what a lot of
y'all have said he's been eating
somebody's getting whing let's go we'll
talk about how it all went down and the
heartbreaking aftermath just like feel
was feeling bad about myself and I'm he
bring me bring all this insecurities
back because D I'm really that ugly I'm
not ugly just like don't
that hey he 90day fans fam it's melissia
I hope you're doing well let's get into
Kanani finding the courage to tell asell
it's over for good Kanani come back to
the resort yesterday morning but I have
not seen her since she first calls an
emergency meeting with the therapist
where she reveals to asell that she
unblocked Dallas the guy he gave her a h
pass a kiss after she suspected asell
was still messaging girls while the
resort if you ask me Kanani was probably
looking for a reason to unblock that man
and I'm not mad at her I thought if he's
going to talk to other people then I
should be able to talk to other people
too look at asu's chest he's breathing
so hard he's nervous and he should be
because what comes next is rough while
trying to keep a straight face Kanani
tells ASU Dallas is in town he told me
that he wanted to come see me mhm and
some is went down he asked if I would
meet him where he was to talk about
things oh snap we ended up doing other
things take some deep
breaths I wanted Kanani to look at him
so bad I was just curious about what her
reaction would be if she saw
this Kanani goes on to tell ASU she sees
that he's trying but it's just too late
like you want div
me
yes Kanani seems to be in a days as she
says yes like she can't even believe
she's saying it wow she finally made the
jump that's what courage looks like
doing it even when you're
scared
yes yes girl you did it seemingly one of
the hardest parts is over meanwhile
asell is rolling around in
agony take your time to
swell the therapist goes on to tell
Kanani and asell that their focus now
will be on building a healthy
co-parenting relationship it's very
difficult for a couple to heal from
repetitive infidelities and repetitive
Affairs because we're looking at that as
a potential addictive and compulsive
nature right and a partner who's
repetitively betrayed has her own what
we call betrayal trauma and it's almost
like an avalanche at some point it's all
going to come down that it is they are
experiencing probably one of the hardest
moments of their lives lives in front of
the world divorce that's not what I want
for my family telling him is just one of
the hardest things that I've ever had to
do because I I have so much love for him
he's the father of my kids and speaking
of the kids if their boys ever want to
know what happened to mommy and daddy's
relationship when they get older they
have this show to watch and it includes
many of the
details I wonder if that's a
conversation ASU is already mentally
preparing for if not hopefully it's
something he's at least thought about I
appreciate the work that you've done
good news is that all love isn't lost
Kanani lets asell know that she still
sees value in him as a friend I know
that's tough to hear but as Liz said in
a previous episode he's lucky to have
that I think we have a great friendship
here the the way you help me with the
boys and then like the conversations we
have and the laughs we have it's great
and I want to keep that and it's a
friendship that's what it is it's a
friendship yeah I don't think I swu
really heard her here because what seems
to be later on that night he starts
talking to the camera about how he hopes
they get back together
hopefully things will change and I'm
hoping
that
stay together again he's gotten too
comfortable with Kanani taking him back
he thinks this is just another one of
those times no this is the
one when is done fast forward Kanani
stops by asu's room and shoots down that
little piece of hope he was holding on
to Well I obviously want to give you
time to process things um but I also
want to be honest and let you know how
I'm feeling about everything so I do
think that it would be best if we just
ride
away
divorce the sooner we get divorced the
better for the kids there's just nothing
more that can be done like I've given
up I just hope that he can deal with
everything and move forward with all of
us now swallo probably cried himself to
sleep that night
I wish them both healing and a graceful
transition into this new stage of their
lives I will punch you in you bring my
all right let's get into jy's swinging
on Big Ed so it all starts when Ed Liz
Angela jie and Yara are on a boat ride
yara's not really talking to Joy because
she's upset that he went to the strip
club behind her back and took the guys
with him she's also just frustrated that
he has a quote obsession with
strippers she doesn't understand I feel
bad for hiding it from her and I deserve
for her to be mad at me right but has a
more conservative approach to sex
because of our cultural differences for
her it's frowned upon but I feel like
it's just entertainment it's all for fun
it's about just you know living in
fantasy land the question is why do you
need to go to Fantasy Land so much what
are you escaping so Ed did did you be
yourself last night for the most part I
did Yara goes on to tell Ed what Joy
said about him and asell joy tell me
that y'all don't behave yall touch
everybody and joy was the only one who
was an angel innocence and just yall
been bad and I don't know if it was the
guilt mixed with the alcohol or
something else but joy shocks everyone
when he snaps at her Michael wants to
tell JY something you get mad on and he
doesn't he he wasn't good you know he
was trying to hide it from me that they
go into the wait say again what you said
y shut
up she wasn't even saying anything when
he said that trying to hide it from me
that they go into the wait say again
what you said yeah shut
up he embarrassed her now she's put in a
position where she has to defend herself
in a classy way on TV as the RO
Housewives franchise proves that's not
always easy I still know how to get Hood
you're gonna talk to me like that you're
gonna go and married to some streer okay
because if they accept that conversation
I don't accept Okay then comes Big Ed
doing what Big Ed does can you ask um
Joy who he was texting last night oh my
go joy can't believe Ed just said that
who were you texting last night
why does Ed choose to be this person who
wants to be the snitch better yet the
tattletail because it just feels so
Elementary oh my God
you're some stripper in Jamaica are you
serious what now come on this ain't
funny now I thought this was the moment
that Joy was going to get up and swing
on Big Ed who I will say it's probably a
reality TV producer's dream he gets
excited to stir the pot look at the
smile on his face here please look at me
and tell me who you text which stripper
in Jamaica no stripper in stripper who
you travel to Jamaica the one he
traveled with
Ed he sounds like he's giving a police
report who you travel to Jamaica the one
he traveled with at the same time joy
and Yara need to lay all the cards on
the table and confront this issue about
the
shippers so in a weird and annoying
way Ed might be helping them I just said
hey do you live in Key West and what
club do you work at and that's
it why you need to know you lit be that
chicken vacation I was looking I know
you was liking her why would you text
her my gosh why would you do that why
would you do that I don't have an answer
I'm sorry what is so bad about your
relationship that you need to all hang
out with the
streepers damn Joby the hell like I just
want to hug Yara and just comfort her
I've not seen that side of Joby and I I
I don't know if it's a hangover but I'm
very upset with him the way he's
treating Yara yeah and it seems as if
this is a common occurrence Yara pushes
for answers and joy shuts down and
dismisses her feelings as if they're not
a big deal why would you check the
Streeter trying to have fun last night
that's it do you have fun with her not
with her when you are married you want
to have fun with a streer I want to have
fun with the guys and that's all I'm
sorry Angela and Liz are shocked and
here goes Big Ed sipping coffee watching
the fire he just lit burn when Yara
threw the the drinks I'm like wow she's
pissed you think I'm feeling really
guilty but it was joy that put me in a
bad position when he asked me to lie to
Liz we want to go to club and have fun
with us four let's go I don't want my
wife to find out don't tell the girls
are you sure she will cut your wavel
off and then he tried to burn me by
telling Yara I wasn't on my best
behavior so in a way he had it coming
well Yara ends up breaking down in tears
and Angela goes to comfort her fast
forward I'm sorry that happened Yar
returns to Joy and asks to see the text
message he sent to the stripper and he
refuses is can I have your fun joy can I
have your fun stop it's over okay what
you do this to me stop you Dr my face oh
no don't you dare try to flip it JY I
want to see like that that's none of my
business but you deserve that I know
that's right me m speak up no I want to
see like that's none of my business but
you deserve that I deserve that I
deserve that I'm not I'm not denying
that I didn't deserve that but like
enough is enough okay that's it listen I
was drunk I up okay and that's it so now
if I get drunk I can go Tex some dude
that's not a good excuse you married if
you like her
then comp with the Streeper I get it you
like the streer I am not AER I wish I be
like that I just don't know what theer
do I need to know what they do to be
like that but I don't know what's they
so special about that something much
deeper is going on with joy and his
relationship with the strip club and
alcohol and it has nothing to do with if
Yara is enough if you want somebody else
then just tell me I am okay like we can
separate and I can leave by myself like
that's fine but why would you choose to
I don't understand the season is almost
over so I don't know if it's going to
come up but I would love to hear them
talk about this with a therapist I feel
like this should have been a
conversation from the beginning forget
Yara sneaking to take birth control yeah
she should have told him but now we see
why she doesn't want to have another kid
right now with him Yara look look at me
please Yara I apologize to you I know
you don't want to hear it right now you
can put that apology to your I'm not in
my opinion it's clear Joy is struggling
with something that has him always
wanting to escape what that is exactly I
don't know he might not even know I feel
like Ed is trying to put me in a worst
situation
all right let's get into the moment
you've been waiting for I'm not mad at
you I just feel like it was it was
unnecessary that's it really necessary
to put between them to bring him to the
street their sh as man why didn't you
explain to your daughter where you were
not the kid why didn't you explain to
your daughter where you were your
daughter about my daughter this look Liz
tries to tell Ed to stop but it's too
late I will punch you in the face if you
bring
my
you bring my into this this your ass
Bring it on I will Big Ed must have a
guardian angel or something on his side
because he always gets away without
getting punched or smacked in the face
when he's loose at the mouth dude this
is so because we come to this resort to
work in our relationship and you texting
all the strippers the episode ends with
Yara confronting Joie about texting the
stripper when they get back to their
room at the resort and the conclusions
she's coming to about herself because of
his
actions are heartbreaking I have no idea
why my husband is so obsessed with
straper and it's always been a way I
tried to look good for him I Tred to
like not let myself go I know I have a
child my body changed but I still go to
the gym every day I try to be I try to
be good for him and I to be honest I'm
so insecure I have so much insecurities
I just like feel was feeling bad about
myself and I'm bring me bring all this
insecurities back because do I'm really
that ugly not ugly just like do I'm
really that bad I get maybe ster doesn't
complain I complain all the time maybe
stripper's like I don't know what that I
cannot do like he
just Joy always been telling me that if
I will not be looking good he will not
be with me so makes sense oh no he
basically told her he's only with her
because of her looks
talk about creating insecurity in your
relationship I don't know if he thought
that was a compliment or what it's also
clear that Yara is still struggling to
let go of the narratives she heard from
her parents growing up my parents for
example was always confirming to
somebody different you need to be a
perfect you need to be
perfect growing up my mom for example
taught me that my nose wasn't so good or
they tell me I'm chunky or something
like
that it just hurt
you but then I grew up and still
thinking sometimes if I gain two extra
pounds then I'm chunky like that's a
it's just something I cannot freaking
cut off she seems to be attaching Joy's
love for the strip club to her
deep-seated belief that she's not good
enough when it has nothing to do with
her he was going to the strip clubs
before he met her same with her mom my
mom for example taught me that my nose
wasn't so good her mom probably didn't
like her own nose or didn't think she
herself was that pretty so she put her
insecurities on her daughter H A lot of
times hurtful things our caregivers said
or did while we were
children end up sticking with us and we
attract relationships as adults that
have us
feeling the same way yara's mom made her
feel like she's not good enough
physically and now Joy's actions are
making her feel like she's not good
enough physically the beautiful part
about all of this though is that
relationships can be our biggest
teachers while jy's actions are
inappropriate in my opinion they also
can serve as a catalyst for Yara to
create a deeper sense of self-love and
acceptance for herself something that
seemed to be shattered when she was a
child and also understand that Joy
doesn't Define her worth no one does not
even her mama only she can do that I
know it's much easier said than done but
hopefully in the end all of this helps
her to realize that G and doy would like
to
start so don't I don't want to talk
about all right next week the couples
have their last group therapy session
and then the commitment ceremony where
they decide if they want to stay
together
or call it quits so we made it to the
end of our Retreat and each and every
single one of you has taken a journey to
be here and now it is time to decide are
you ready to
rededicate if we can't recommit to each
other I'm going to lose her I think
she's
done I'm worried after this boat ride
Fiasco I don't really know what's the
state of my marriage it's uh tough my
mind's all over the place right now all
right 90day fans famam make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all I will see you next
time